-Our next guest is
a talented actress
who wrote, produced and, stars
in "Shelter in Solitude",
which will be in theaters
October 6th.
Let's take a look.
-Normally,
the way a conversation goes
is, "Do you have children?
You have kids?"
"No. Do you, Valerie?"
"No, I don't, Jackson."
"Why don't you, Valerie?"
"Oh, because...
I never married."
-Why not?
-I don't know.
My daddy always said it was
'cause I intimidated the boys
'cause I had
unearned effervescence.
-Please welcome to the show,
Siobhan Fallon Hogan.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I'm so happy to have you here.
-I am thrilled to be here, Seth.
I'm thrilled.
-So you used to work
in this building
at a "Saturday Night Live".
Have you been back since then?
-I just went over there,
and I said,
"Does anybody remember me?"
And they said,
"What year are you here?"
I said, "20- and, uh,
20- and -2000 years ago."
-[ Laughs ]
And they hate doing the math.
-They're like, "Who are ya?"
-[ Laughs ]
-I actually said, "1902",
but I forgot my joke.
[ Laughter ]
-So now you --
you wrote, you produced,
and you starred in this movie.
-Yes.
-I know how hard it can be
to make an independent film
like this.
How long did it take the process
from start to finish?
-Start to finish? Okay.
I was laying in bed one night
in the middle of the night.
I had written
a movie called "Rushed",
which came out two years ago,
and I said I'm taking a break
because I'm elderly.
And so, I -- then this idea
came to me
in the middle of the night.
My dad had been an attorney --
I'm from five kids,
I'm the second of five --
and he used to tell us
about these prisoners,
that he represented,
at our -- at our kitchen table.
And I'd be kind of, like,
terrified but really fascinated.
And so, he also wanted me
to be a country
[Voice raises] singer,
[Normal voice]
but I didn't have the voice.
-Oh, I thought the way
you said "singer" was beautiful.
-You like that?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-I'm affected. So... Okay.
So, I have red nails.
I got it going on for the show.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-So, okay...
So anyway, so this idea
came to me
in the middle of the night,
and I said,
"What if a prisoner
has 10 days left to live
and a washed up country singer
becomes his guard?"
And so, that's where
the idea came from.
And I said, "Wait a minute,
I got to have Robert Patrick
in there", you know,
from "The Terminator".
He's fabulous, and he played
my husband in "Rushed".
I was like,
"We need a hard ass warden."
And so --
I wasn't supposed to swear.
Sorry.
-That's okay.
-And so, anyway,
that's where it came from.
And then I wrote it
in three weeks,
and we filmed it in 16 days.
-That's incredible.
That is not a lot of time.
-No.
-You produced it
with your husband, but you also
involved your children.
-Yes. My son is a producer.
He's a music supervisor,
which, by the way,
he would freak out
about your band.
I'm, like, back there rocking.
I'm like,
he loves music so much.
And he hooked me up
with Justin Biltonen
from 3 Doors Down
for country fans.
I sang with him last Tuesday
in Nashville.
-Look at you.
-Uh-huh.
-Who's not a country singer?
-Come on.
I was on a rooftop singing --
He wrote this song
"Heartache Rodeo".
-Okay. Were other people
on the rooftop?
Or was that something
you chose to do? Yeah.
-Well, my son booked it all.
-Oh, great.
-And then my daughter, Sinead,
I gotta mention her --
I'll get punched in the face
when I get home --
she -- she was the production
designer.
And then my daughter,
Bernadette, she's a journalist.
So, she would help me the copy.
Anyway, we're all involved.
Even the dog. It's called
Trudy Ville, the town.
So we're all in on it.
And my son plays Chris, the cop.
And, you know,
it was an insane asylum
because I'm not nocturnal.
-Yeah.
-And so, that's why,
like, whatever.
But anyway,
I'd say there's rules.
Okay? We have to have rules.
No one listens to me.
You know, we're an Irish family.
It's ridiculous.
And so, I said,
"Do not wake me up.
We're filming this movie.
I'm the producer.
I have to, like,
get the porta potty --"
-You need your sleep, yeah.
-Yeah, I gotta make sure
the porta potties are clean.
My husband's getting food
for the crew,
and my son knock on the door
at 2:00 in the morning,
"Um, can I talk to you
about that scene?"
I go, "I thought --
I thought we had a rule."
And he's like, "I'm sorry,
but I think we should say,
'Skedaddle, Valerie.'
And then you should say,
'Skedaddle' back."
And I go, "That's funny.
Come in."
So -- So I look terrible
in the movie,
but I'm supposed to be
washed up, so it doesn't matter.
-Oh, yeah. There you go.
That's very smart.
-I mean -- I mean,
what is happening under my eyes?
I don't know.
-You, like, save money
on a makeup person
when you just stay up all night.
-Completely. And I was --
And I was also a cougar wannabe.
-Oh, yeah?
-Yeah, and so,
I'm supposed to try
to have an affair --
well, try is --
heavy on the try --
with this Michael Oberholtzer,
who's a fabulous actor.
But I want to give a massive,
massive shout out.
Peter Macon, the guy
who plays the actor
who plays the prisoner --
-Yeah, the death row inmate.
-...it was an Oscar worthy
performance.
-That's fantastic.
You also --
I know you filmed it
in Syracuse,
which is where you're from.
Did you actually
cast some locals
that you knew back in the day?
-Oh, I did. I --
Matter of fact --
So the bar scenes,
which it didn't rain
the whole time,
which is really unusual
for Syracuse,
and so, the only days
it rained was the bar.
And guess how I got
all my extras?
-How? Free beer?
-Thanks for asking.
Close, I said to the class
of '79,
which not to date myself,
I said to my class, "Whoever
wants to be an extra can come
and be in the bar scene."
So that's my entire class
from '79.
-Oh, my God.
-Yeah.
-That's fantastic.
They all showed up for you?
-They all showed.
People flew in from all over.
And it's literally like,
I go to Nashville,
they come there,
I'm like, I have an entour--
Like, when I was on "SNL",
I remember MC Hammer came
and he had, like, an entourage.
-Yeah.
-And now I have one.
-It just took you
a little bit longer
to reach your Hammer era.
-Yeah.
Guess what else I have?
-What?
-So...
[ Laughter ]
I probably shouldn't say this.
-You have the energy
of someone who probably
shouldn't say it.
-Should I not?
-Say it.
-I have a perv. I have a perv.
Somebody called me and, like,
did weird breathing.
-You have your own perv?
-And I go, "I made it."
-Oh, my God.
Siobhan, we're so --
we're so happy for you.
-Yes.
I went over. I went o--
Matter of fact,
I went over
to "Saturday Night Live".
You know, I had PTSD
when I came 'cause, you know...
-Yeah.
-Well, you know, I left
for "artistic differences" --
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-...in '92.
Anyway, so I went over,
and I went on the stage,
and the guys were so nice.
And I said, "Live from New York,
it's Wednesday night.
I'm on Seth Meyers show."
-Well, there you go.
And here you are.
And congratulations
on the movie.
Everybody, check it out.
It's an independent film.
These are the kind of movies
we need to go see.
You guys,
that is Siobhan Fallon Hogan.
"Shelter in Solitude"
in theaters October 6th.
Go see it and stick around.
We'll be right back
with music from Jungle.